Antarctica might not be the first place
to look for a mountaineering adventure
thousands of climbers around the world
though focus on famous peaks like Mount
Everest k2 Denali and the Matterhorn but
only handful have tried to climb the
isolated and frozen granite walls at the
bottom of the world only on CBS this
morning we're introducing you to the
North Face climbing team that took on
the chilling challenge to summit six
mountains in Antarctica when this
massive cargo plane lifted off from Cape
Town South Africa
it was carrying 1,700 pounds of extreme
cold weather gear and six of the best
rock climbers and Mountaineers in the
world
their destination almost six hours
flight due south a rugged and remote
region of Antarctica called Queen Maud
land there's kind of a elliptical ring
of mountains and there's six peaks with
walls between two and three thousand
feet tall for a climbing legend like
team leader Conrad Anker those walls
which very few people have ever seen
much less scaled are irresistible the
fact that it's always below freezing
makes it a challenge for wall climbers
the remoteness the cliff face and the
temperature any one of them can get us
but all three together you always have
to manage that risk on a day to day
basis yosemite search-and-rescue vet
cedar Wright came up with the idea for
the all-star Antarctica adventure if you
go out deep into the center of that wild
unexplored continent you find one of the
most impressive ranges of granite in the
world I look at it like Assaf rosen
Yosemite each of these formations is at
least if not bigger than El Cap it just
kind of takes all the skills that we've
learned in places like Yosemite and
brings them to this really wild and
severe environment yosemite and its
sheer granite monster El Capitan is the
most famous training ground for
expeditions like Queen Maud land and no
one has conquered El Capitan like Alex
Honnold this past June he achieved the
holy grail of rock climbing a rope list
solo free climb up its 3,000 foot face
his biggest challenge in Antarctica
temperatures hovering right around
freezing and below my lips are too
chapped life is good here in America
when you first touch cold rock your
fingers will get numb but then after the
initial numbing blood rushes back to
your fingers it really really hurts when
the blood rushes back into your
fingertips so it makes you want to
scream and you can feel sick you have
cold it is
called Jimmy Chin's long career has
acclimated him to the cold place but
that happens when you accomplish feats
like he did in 2006 when he skied off
the summit of Mount Everest
it might seem all downhill from Everest
to Antarctica but for chin
none of it would be possible without El
Capitan you have to be really
comfortable on El Cap in order to go
down and think about climbing in Queen
Maud land because you drop the
temperature from 70 degrees to negative
20 and then you put it in someplace
that's totally inaccessible and remote
the stakes become quite a bit higher the
stakes for Ana pfaff and her climbing
partner Savannah Cummins are even higher
they're the only women on this
expedition which is the sort of journey
that typically is all male
they hope the trip helps them move the
sport forward SEC I would like to get
more women in the sport of doing this
kind of stuff there's still the stigma
that you know the mountains are made for
men I've had people say these things to
me before and what it's done to me is
it's this made me want to try harder ana
and Savannah are every bit as capable as
the dudes on our team everyone should go
to an on a can climb a big wall or six
those stunning images come from the
team's documentary film crew which
captured every moment of this incredible
expedition and in the new year they will
join us here at the table on CBS this
morning with more footage and stories
from their Alpine adventures at the
bottom of the world and I love seeing
the Everest guys that we were following
the last couple years that did their
Everest expedition on social media
reaching out and congratulating them and
sort of saying reach for these goals and
a family yeah really is actually do that
I love seeing the women - yeah it's so
inspirational
I feel so inadequate but I'll stay here
at the team yeah all the questions we
need to